et comme chaque semaine en termine avec
notre rubrique coupe du monde qui vous
est chère laurence puisque l um donne
l'occasion d'aller à la rencontre de
tous ceux qui de près ou de loin
s'intéressent au ballon rond
parfois avec beaucoup d'humour et de
distance ça me fait mal de mal à
personne et c'est signé guy bedos
ce que je crains le plus c'est laisser
les tirs au but parce que c'est ça va
faire des crises cardiaques cet
interminable et puis je procure à
beaucoup de divorces d'adultère et
choses comme ça pendant le mondial quoi
parce que les femmes pensent aux femmes
qui se foutent du fou j'aime bien les
joueurs j'en connais certains jouaient
au foot c'est formidable c'est les
supporteurs qui me rendent fous et c'est
ce qui me fait peur dans le fanatisme
qui lie à pour le fou de cet esprit de
parti de soutien inconditionnel à une
éclipse à quai le contre est moins de
l'esprit sportif c'est que ça ouvre la
porte à tous les fanatismes
j'ai joué moi quand j'ai des jeux mame
algérie
et jouer arrière et m'est arrivé parce
que c'est ma nature de marquer des buts
à mon propre camp